Film Courage: What are five thing a director
should never do on set?
Chloe Carroll, Actor/Director: No know the
story, not understand the scene completely
so when an actor asks the question they are
like “I don’t know?”
Not put an actor under pressure because of
the time constraints of production to get
a performance.
Obviously you will need to get the shot in
time but I think by not letting the actor
be aware of the set and the time constraints
is really helpful because you’re not…I
think without the pressure they will give
a better performance and to try and keep that
separate.
I think that is why the director is really
the only person who talks to the actors.
They are not in the conversations with the
camera person and the camera person would
talk to the director.
They kind of keep it all the way so they can
just concentrate on the performance.
I think a director has to care about the movie
so not caring about it.
When you’re on the set and you can tell
that the director is not that particularly
or they are doing it for money and they are
not really into the story, I think it shows.
I think a director you pick on every production
should really care about the story or be really
excited and want to do it.
I think that is really important.
Film Courage: I like what you said (just real
quickly) about protecting them [the actors].
So is it almost like protecting a child from
knowing certain news so then the actor is
going to be protected while on set?
Chloe: Yes so they don’t have to worry about
anything but the character because that was
one thing with producing THE HONEYMOON PHASE
close to actually filming it.
I was not doing as much producing work as
I was doing the acting so that I wasn’t
like Oh my gosh now we have to do this for
tomorrow and this on set as I was acting and
worrying about that too much that it’s just
like let the actor do their thing and not
have their outside worries as so important
because I think that they will deliver a better
performance because they are not pressured
and not worried about other things.
Their mind is only on the character.
For me that’s huge.
So if I direct…I’ve only directed little
shorts but I tried to do that.
Film Courage: But I’m sure that shorts is
something that will add up.
Do you think you’ll ever do a feature in
the next four years.
Chloe: Direct a feature?
I thought about it.
Eventually.
I don’t know if I’ll direct.
I like directing.
I like directing but I don’t like…it’s
so stressful I feel to direct because you
are the core person on that production that
everyone looks to everything for and I think
if it was like a really cool horror story
I would direct but I’d have to be really
into it to feel like I would do it justice
as the director.
Maybe I guess?
But I prefer acting and producing they are
my two favorite things.
Question: What is something a director should
never do on set?